Tod und Trauer das ist die Realität seit
Wochen in Israel und in Gaza noch immer
sind über 200 Geiseln in der Gewalt der
Hamas und gestern wurde bekannt dass die
deutsche junge Frau Shani Luk ermordet
wurde Israels Soldaten kämpfen nun auch
am Boden gegen die Terroristen die
wiederum feuern weiter Raketen in
Richtung Tel Aviv die Lage der Menschen
in Gaza ist verzweifelt und die
umstrittene unoesolution für einen
Waffenstillstand bleibt ohne Wirkung und
die Sorge vor einer globalen Ausweitung
des Konfliktes wächst Israels Vorstoß in
Gaza wohin führt der Krieg unser Thema
in der
phönixrunde
phönixrunde guten Abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus Berlin das sind meine
Gäste Daniela schwarzer ist bei uns
Politikwissenschaftlerin Mitglied des
Vorstands der Bertelsmannstiftung und
Expertin für europäische und
internationale Angelegenheiten ich
begrüße Samia schaffi sie ist
Redakteurin mit dem Schwerpunkt
Außenpolitik bei der Wochenzeitung Die
Zeit und herzlich willkommen Markus kein
Keim Entschuldigung Senior fellow bei
der Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik
mit dem Schwerpunkt Sicherheitspolitik
und zugeschaltet in Tel Aviv ist mein
Kollege Julius Segador er ist
Korrespondent dort im
D Studio und Herr Segador mit ihnen
würde ich auch ganz gerne
beginnen die israelischen Soldaten
Rücken vor in Gaza offiziell heißt es
aber nicht Bodenoffensive also was
wissen wir eigentlich über das was da im
Moment Moment passiert na ja es ist
schon die Bodenoffensive davon kann man
wirklich ausgehen und wenn ich den
Generalstabschef hanekbi zitiere der
gesagt hat wir greifen Gasa an mit einer
nie gekannten Feuerkraft dann ist das
die Bodenoffensive und wir haben ja
gesehen dass die Soldaten die jetzt in
den gaserstreifen rein sind seit Freitag
nicht mehr rausgehen und Sie haben ja
bodengewinne die sie
erzielen und nicht nur im Norden sie
rücken immer weiter Richtung Gaza Stadt
vor also das ist die Bodenoffensive mit
sehr sehr heftigen Kämpfen also das ist
die eine Seite die andere Seite ist und
wir mussten das hier vor wenigen Minuten
wieder erleben dass aus dem
gaserstreifen immer noch kräftig
Raketenbeschuss nach Israel kommt heute
wie gesagt vor etwa einer Stunde drei
wirklich ja ich habe so noch nie gesehen
mit einem Feuerschweif am Nachthimmel
drei Raketen über Tel Aviv die der Iron
Dome abgefangen hat und die schrabnelle
die fielen dann wirklich hier neben das
Studio also sie merken auf beiden Seiten
das ist der der Krieg den wir so erleben
und ich war gestern in sterot das ist
eine Stadt die evakuiert worden ist eine
30.000
Einwohnerstadt auf einem Hügel nur 800 m
vom Grenzzaun entfernt und was man da
hört mit welcher Feuerkraft Israel den
gaserstreifen angreift mit der
Artillerie mit den Jets mit Panzern und
natürlich dann auch mit mit Drohnen das
ist wirklich unglaublich und wenn man an
die Menschen denkt die dort sind dann
können ein die ein wirklich nur leid tun
wir haben heute ja gehört dass ein
Flüchtlingslager bombardiert wurde von
Israel was wissen sie dazu da geht es um
das Flüchtlingslager jabalia ein
Flüchtlingslager das eigentlich seit
1948 Bestand hat die Menschen leben da
in diesen flüchtlingslag in dritte und
vierte Generation
m es ist beschossen worden weil dort und
das ist eben auch Teil dieser ja
perfiden Kriegstaktik der Hamas weil
dort eben in dem Kriegslager äh bei
zivilen
Gebäuden Krankenhäusern Schulen wichtige
Kommandozentralen der hammerswahn
Stellungen der Hamas Abschussrampen für
Mörsergranaten und die sind heute
beschossen worden wir wissen ja dass das
israelische Militär seit Tagen schon die
Bevölkerung aufgefordert hat dass sie in
den Südteil des Küstenstreifens geht und
die Hamas wir wissen das auch aus den
Berichten unserer Mitarbeiter die wir
noch im gaserstreifen haben die hindert
die Menschen zum Teil daran eben in den
Süden zu gehen weil sie als menschliche
Schutzschilde dienen und deshalb dann
auch wie heute sehr viele zivile Opfer
mhm ja vielen Dank sie bleiben ja bei
uns während der ganzen Sendung
herzlichen Dank dafür schon mal jetzt
Herr Keim wenn man das sieht wie wie
stark Israel jetzt vorgeht da im
Gazastreifen ist das ist das die
richtige Taktik um die Hammers ja zu
besiegen zu bekämpfen auszuschalten zu
vernichten es gibt ja alle möglichen
Worte die da auf einmal genutzt werden
ich finde das ist der kleiner Punkt den
sie sagen äh die israelische Politik ist
ein bisschen unklar was genau erreicht
werden soll sie ist etwas unklar bei dem
politischen Endziel also wenn die
militärische Operation einmal eines
schönen Tages beendet sein soll muss ja
ein politischer Endzustand
wiederhergestellt werden auf den wir
sicher noch zu sprechen kommen dass sie
ganz schweigsam aber tatsächlich auch
bei dem vorgelagerten bei der
vorgelagerten Frage was heißt denn die
Hamas zu besiegen heißt das die
politische Führung auszuschalten heißt
das die Infrastruktur kurz und klein zu
schlagen heißt das den gaserstreifen
unbewohnbar zu machen auch das ist ja
zumindest bis dann im Unklaren geblieben
und das wird sich in den nächsten Tagen
und Wochen wahrscheinlich dann so
langsam herausbilden und der israelische
Ministerpräsident spricht ja sogar von
Monaten also das wird langer Krieg
werden mhm Frau schaffi was heißt das
für die Menschen in Gaza wenn wir das
gehört haben sie werden genutzt als
menschliche ja Schutzschilde worauf
können sich die müssen sich die Menschen
dort einstellen wie wie kann es dort
weitergehen für die
Zivilbevölkerung das ist eine Frage die
glaub habe ich unser
Vorstellungsvermögen
überschreitet also wie die Situation der
Menschen dort jetzt ist man muss sich
vor Augen halten die Menschen dort es
sind über 2 Millionen Menschen die in
diesem Territorium leben das ist die
Bevölkerung von Hamburg der
gaserstreifen als ganzer ist aber nur
halb so groß wie Hamburg und die Leute
haben dort schon vor diesem Krieg Hunger
gelitten 75% der Menschen hatten nicht
genug zu essen sie waren eingesperrt
mehr oder weniger konnten das
Territorium kaum verlassen oder gar
nicht verlassen lassen und jetzt werden
sie aus der Luft bombardiert jetzt ist
die Bodenoffensive gestartet sie können
in den Süden flüchten aber auch dort
müssen sie ja mit Bombardierungen
rechnen also es gibt keinerlei
Sicherheit keinerlei
m Schutz in Wahrheit für diese Menschen
und es mangelt ihnen eben an allem es
mangelt ihnen an Nahrung an Wasser an
Medizin an Strom also ist
eine unvstellbare verantwortlich machen
dass es an allem mangelt wenn ich
verantwortlich
mache ähm natürlich hat die Hamas diesen
Konflikt ausgelöst die Hamas ist eine
terroristische Organisation die Israel
angegriffen hat wohlwissend dass es
massive Konsequenzen haben würde und das
in Kauf nehmend sie benutzt die
Bevölkerung als Schutzschilde wie es
schon gesagt wurde ähm das ist das ist
die Wahrheit das lässt sich nicht
bestreiten israel hatte keine Wahl als
zu reagieren und trotzdem manchmal
gibt's mehr als eine Wahrheit die
gleichzeitig existiert ist es moralisch
nicht zu rechtfertigen was diese
Zivilbevölkerung jetzt erleben muss mhm
die USA haben sich ja auch für ein ja
erstmal so ein hinauszöern auch der
brudenöffensive ausgesprochen und auch
beiden hat ja auch sehr darf drauf
gedrängt dass man die
humanitären Werte da nicht außer Acht
lassen soll also wie sehr steht die ja
stehen die USA und auch die
internationale Gemeinschaft da zu diesem
zu der Bodenoffensive der tun der USA
hat sich tatsächlich in den vergangenen
Wochen verändert zu Beginn als Hamas
Israel angegriffen hat also als das die
Greueltaten der Terroristen so richtig
klar wurden da hat die USA sich erstmal
sehr bedingungslos hinter Israel
gestellt und gesagt wir unterstützen
euch ihr habt ein Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung wir sind da und in
den vergangenen Wochen und gerade auch
jetzt heute noch mal ist der Ton aus
Washington etwas distanzierter geworden
und zwar haben der Verteidigungsminister
der Außenminister waren beide zu
Anhörung im Senat und haben sehr klar
gesagt es ist Israels Entscheidung wie
dieser Krieg geführt wird da wurde also
eine gewisse Distanz aufgebaut immer
wieder wird betont dass der Schutz der
Zivilisten wichtig ist und beachtet
werden muss und es wird auch gesagt dass
die Geisel natürlich irgendwie geschützt
werden müssen insofern sieht man auf
Seiten der USA eine eine gewisse
Vorsicht was sicherlich auch mit der
innenpolitischen Lage zu tun hat aber
keine Infragestellung dass die USA an
der Seite Israels stehen her segadur
kommen wir mal auf die auf die Geisel
Frau Schwarzer hat gerade angesprochen
wir haben ja gestern die Nachricht
erhalten dass die junge Frau Shani lu
ermordet worden ist wobei nicht ganz
klar ist ob sie wirklich schon direkt an
dem ersten Tag ermordet wurde wie sehr
oder welche Rolle spielen die Geiseln im
Moment noch für diesen für diese
Bodenoffensive aber auch in der in der
Bevölkerung in Israel ich habaub da muss
man unterscheiden natürlich ist es ein
Kriegsziel auch die Geiseln zu befreien
das ist ein Ziel das die Regierung
permanent betont aber man muss ganz klar
sagen dass glaube ich die militärische
Dimension dieses Konfliktes für die
Regierung im Vordergrund steht auf der
anderen Seite haben wir hier im Land
inzwischen eine sehr sehr große
Diskussion weil natürlich die
Angehörigen der Verschleppten Menschen
die
die viele aus der Bevölkerung die eine
große große Empathie und Empfinden für
für diesen Kreis die sagen wir haben ja
gesehen dass bereits vier Geiseln
freigelassen worden sind es ist ja
möglich
möglicherweise auf dem Verhandlungsweg
hier mehr zu zu erreichen und das ist
eine Diskussion der sich die Regierung
stellen muss die aber in meinen Augen so
auch nicht richtig geführt wird man hat
gesehen vor zwei Tagen hat sich premier
Benjamin netanah zum ersten Mal auch mit
Angehörigen der Geiseln getroffen er
wurde dann in einer Pressekonferenz kurz
danach konkret gefragt was denn
eigentlich der Kurs ist mit den Geiseln
und da hat er relativ nebulösen
ausweichend geantwortet dann kam gestern
natürlich die als als Meldung hinzu das
hat der Regierung sicherlich in die
Hände gespielt dass eine Geisel befreit
werden konnte eine Soldatin wobei man
nicht genau weiß ob sie wirklich in der
Hand der Hamas war oder von Zivilisten
in Gaza gefangen gehalten wurde und das
ist natürlich auch wieder ein Thema was
die Regierung und vor allem das Militär
jetzt auch groß gespielt hat sie haben
gesagt seht her es ist möglich dass wir
im Rahmen dieser Bodenoffensive auch
Geiseln befreien können aber wir reden
jetzt über fünf Geiseln insgesamt die
freig kommen sind von 240 mindestens und
es werden wohl mehr sein also es ist ein
sehr sehr langer Weg und meine
Einschätzung ist ganz klar wenn diese
Bodenoffensive weitergeht das wird ein
sehr sehr blutiger Häuserkampf darauf
kann man sich einstellen das hat sich
heute schon gezeigt wenn
die ersten Todesmeldungen israelischer
Soldaten hier verkündet werden das wird
sehr sehr blutig werden und dann muss
man sich glaube ich auch wirklich vor
Augen halten dass die Geiseln
buchstäblich zwischen den Fronten stehen
werden möglicherweise von den
Terroristen dann auch als menschliche
Schutzschilde genommen werden benutzt
werden wie muss ich mir das vorstellen
her Keim in einem ja kriegerischen
Konflikt wie wie welche Rolle spielen
dann Geisen und wie werden sie sozusagen
ja benutzt
ausgenutzt also im westlichen Kontext
hab eher wenig Erfahrung damit also dass
Geiseln in Konflikten eingesetzt werden
die deutle Soldaten geführt hätten in
den vergangenen Jahren da ist mir kein
einziger Fall bekannt und auch ischer
Soldaten sind damit wenig konfrontiert
worden aber tatsächlich ist genauso wie
gerade angesprochen das Thema Mens
menschliche schutzchelde und V allem
muss muss vielleicht noch da drunter
legen und das passt passt das Bild die
vermutlich oder angeblich 900 km
Tunnelsysteme unter Gasa ob diese Zahl
stimmt kann ich nicht kontrollieren das
kann wahrscheinlich niemand
kontrollieren aber sie wird immer
kolportiert die sozusagen dann genutzt
werden können um diese Geisel nicht nur
zu verbergen sondern auch an andere Orte
zu verbringen also ist ja nicht damit
getan sie einmal zu lokalisieren und
dann ein mit einer Kommandoaktion
einzelne Geisel zu befreien sonder steht
zu befürchten dass sie sobald der Ort
identifiziert ist ein andere ter
gebracht werden und das macht den Punkt
ja noch viel stärker den wir gerade
gehört haben Zusagen die Suche nach den
Geiseln wird das militärische Vorgehen
eher verzögern aufhalten was das Militär
nicht will und die Politik noch viel
weniger als kommt z Zielkonflikt
zwischen unterschiedlichen militärischen
und politischen Zielen und die Frage ist
ja auch aber sind ja welche schon frei
gekommen ausländische Geiseln auch Frau
Schwarzer wie wie kann muss man sich das
vorstellen wie da im Hintergrund me
verhandelt wird was weiß man darüber
darüber wissen wir relativ wenig es wird
allerdings bestätigt dass Qatar eine
gewisse Rolle spielt die Amerikaner ähm
versuchen das natürlich äh ich glaube
alle Kräfte die im Moment versucht haben
Israel die den Bodeneinsatz zu zu
verzögern oder zu mäßigen hatten immer
im Blick dass es da vielleicht noch ein
verhandlungsfenster gibt und im Moment
ist die Situation einfach hochgefährlich
für die Geiseln das heißt nicht dass die
Verhandlungsversuche eingestellt werden
aber es wird immer schwieriger mhm und
es wurde aber auch schon angesprochen
dass es eine mögliche eventuell einen
Austausch gab wir es gab ja den damals
diesen israelischen Soldaten gilat
schalid der dann gegen glaube ich 1000
Palästinenser ausgetauscht wurde also
gibt es da Möglichkeiten ja gilat
schalet würde damals gegen über 1000
palästinensische Gefangene glaube ich
ausgetauscht und darunter waren unter
den damals freigelassen waren ja jetzt
auch waren auch
Leute die jetzt in der hammersführende
Rollen
spielen deswegen ist die Frage ob ein
solcher Tausch noch einmal zustande
kommen kann und wird äh darüber
verhandelt wird dass das ist so aber ob
es tatsächlich passieren wird ist meines
Wissens noch sehr
unklar W wenn noch was sagen könnte wir
hatten ja den Vorschlag vor zwei Tagen v
Sinn war das ist der wohl ranghöchste
Hamas Vertreter der noch im
gazerastreifen ist soweit man das sagen
kann also der hamascheff der nicht jetzt
in in Qatar oder im im Libanon ist und
der hat ja gesagt ein Vorschlag wäre
alle gegen alle das heißt dass alle
Geiseln die jetzt im Gazastreifen sind
freigelassen werden gegen diese 6000
palästinensischen Häftlinge in
israelischen Gefängnissen aber das sind
natürlich Vorschläge die nie als
Verhandlung wirklich auf Israel mit der
has nicht verhandelt und ich glaube auch
nicht dass es dazu kommen könnte und man
sieht ja jetzt auch ganz gut dass die
Hamas das Thema Geiseln ja wirklich als
Teil einer psychologischen Kriegsführung
benutzt da werden wirklich
tröpfchenweise Geiseln rausgelassen es
werden immer wieder es wird immer wieder
angekündigt auch heute dass Geiseln
möglicherweise jetzt mit ausländische
Staatsangehörigkeit keine Israelis
freigelassen werden aber es geschieht ja
nicht also es ist es ist Teil dieser
wirklich psychologischen Kriegsführung
der Hamas das weiß Israel und das
Kriegsziel und ich glaube schon dass das
definiert ist das Kriegsziel ist dass
Israel aus dem Gazastreifen nie mehr
gefähdet wird dass die Sicherheit
Israels nie mehr aus dieser Region
gefähdert ist und wenn man jetzt diese
6000 palästinensischen Häftlinge aus den
Gefängnissen hier in Israel entlassen
würde dann wäre das ja kontraproduktiv
also ich glaube dass es dazu nie im
Leben kommen wird Herr es würde ja auch
der politischen Dynamik entgegenlaufen
also ich meine sie sind in Israel sie
sind da viel me dran sie können das
besser beurteilen aber es scheint do so
zu sein dass in den letzten drei Wochen
eine Dynamik obsiegt hat jetzt muss
jemand für den 7 Oktober bezahlen wir W
wir die Hamas dafür bestrafen und in
einer solchen Stimmung bis zum Beweis
des Gegenteils bis die Militäroffensive
vielleicht auf Widerstand stößt oder
ganz scheitern sollte wir wissen es
nicht ist glaube ich für so eine
Verhandlungslösung auch auch unter
innenpolitischen Aspekt in Israel
wahrscheinlich überhaupt keine Chance
Benjamin nan hat ja gesagt jetzt ist
Zeit für Krieg und hat sich gegen den
Waffenstillstand
ausgesprochen Frau Schwarzer was wie
viel Rückhalt hat er international oder
gibt es eine Möglichkeit ihn doch
irgendwie dazu ja Ja zu zwingen zu
drängen na ja im Moment glaube ich gibt
es kaum eine Chance ihn davon abzuhalten
die Ziele sind sind relativ klar er hat
den Verteidigungsfall ausgerufen er
möchte die Bedrohung aus dem
Gazastreifen beenden und geht damit
jetzt auch mit Bodentruppen vor das ist
also meiner Ansicht nach ein natürlich
ein hohes Risiko für die israelische
Armee aber das scheint er bereit zu sein
zu tragen das heißt also der Preis ist
es ihm wert
ich glaube es noch mal interessant auf
auf die Amerikaner zu gucken weil wenn
irgendjemand ihn davon abhalten könnte
dann wären das die Amerikaner die Israel
als als Militär er Partner jetzt
sichtbar natürlich durch die Verlagerung
von zwei Flugzeugträgern durch die
Zusage von militärischer und
finanzieller
Unterstützung unterstützen Joe Biden hat
jetzt noch mal ein 14 Milliarden Dollar
Paket in den Kongress eingebracht zur
Unterstützung Israels also da sieht man
eigentlich nicht dass der wichtigste
Unterstützer sich abkehrt die Europäer
sind sind da gespalten wie sie sich in
dem Konflikt positionieren die v
urteilung des terroristischen Angriffs
war klar
allerdings haben die EU-Staaten schon um
ihr erstes Statement wirklich lange
gerungen weil es
gegenüber gegenüber Israel gegenüber der
arabischen Welt gegenüber den Muslimen
im eigenen Land in jedem EU-Staat
unterschiedliche
ja unterschiedliche erwegungen gibt und
das macht das gemeinsame Handeln der
EU27 im Moment sehr schwierig und sehr
sehr langsam Frau schaffi wie beurteilen
Sie das Handeln der EU und ähm heißt das
dadurch dass die EU das nicht so klar
gemeinsam in eine Linie folgt dass
letztendlich es wirklich nur auf die USA
ankommen ich glaube schon dass die USA
die maßgeblichen Verbündeten sind die
wenn überhaupt auf Israel einwirken
können schon allein deshalb weil sie sie
eben auch militärisch so stark
unterstützen
und das hört man ja auch aus den
Berichten dass sie da sehr hinter den
Kulissen auch sehr einzuwirken versuchen
sie haben dazu geraten die Boden
Offensive zu verzögern sie stehen jetzt
mit taktischen Ratschlägen an der Seite
Israels und die Europäer sprechen eben
nicht mit einer Stimme das tun sie in
vielen Themen nicht und das tun sie in
diesem eben auch nicht das hat man jetzt
auch wieder gesehen bei dieser
unresolution wo es eben keine gemeinsame
Haltung der europäischen Staaten gab
sondern frankreich hat ja gestimmt
Deutschland hat sich enthalten andere
haben abgelehnt also da ist es eben
leider so dass die EU kein ein Akteur
ist der eine wirkliche Wirkung haben
könnte bisl her Herr Segador wie schaut
man aus Israel auf diese ja auf die
Rolle der USA und auch auf die
unresolution die halt eben von
Deutschland wo Deutschland sich
enthalten hat und
nicht eben anders gestimmt hat als die
USA wie welche Wirkungen hat das in in
Israel also was den Rückhalt der
Vereinigten Staaten anbelangt da war
ganz klar es war also dieser dieser
Feldzug jetzt nach Gaza wäre nicht
möglich gewesen wenn ich Joe Biden sehr
sehr früh grünes Licht gegeben hätte und
das haben die Vereinigten Staaten
gemacht Joe Biden ist zu einem sehr sehr
frühen Zeitpunkt in ein Kriegsgebiet
gekommen das gab es auch nicht häufig
dass ein US-Präsident in in die
Kriegszone kommt und er ist ja wirklich
auch an den Rand zum Gasastreifen hin
anders alss als Kanzler Scholz der nur
in Anführungszeichen hier in Tel Aviv
war also dieser Rückhalt ist unglaublich
wichtig und die USA sind schon so ein
bisschen das Regulativ jetzt weniger vom
militärischen weil ich glaube dass da äh
sich die israelische Regierung auch
nicht reinreden lässt da gab es dieses
grüne Licht aber vor allem was die
Zivilbevölkerung im Süden des
küstenstreibens anbelangt also ich
glaube da können die Vereinigten Staaten
wirklich viel einwirken dass jetzt z.B
einfach mehr Hilfstransporte über die
Grenze aus Ägypten nach Israel nach Gaza
reingehen da da können sie wirklich viel
machen
der zweite Teil Ihrer Frage die
Resolution das ist verherend angekommen
also gerade die deutsche Enthaltung ist
hier in Israel sehr sehr kritisch von
der Regierung aufgenommen worden weil in
dieser UN-Resolution ja der Terror der
Hamas überhaupt nicht verurteilt worden
ist oder nur sehr sehr gering und das
ist ein Punkt der hier sehr sehr
aufmerksam verfolgt worden ist dass es
da nur eine Enthaltung war und dass man
nicht gegen die Resolution gestimmt hat
und es gab auch die entsprechenden
enttäuschten Kommentare Herr war es
richtig dass Deutschland sich enthalten
hat ich fand das eine sehr unglückliche
Entscheidung weil man damit das Ganze
narrativ der letzten drei Wochen
Stichwort staatsreson Israels Sicherheit
damit unterminiert hat ich verstehe das
Argument des Auswärtigen Amtes so es es
ja offiziell begründet worden wir wollen
unsere Gesprächskanäle zu vielen
arabischen Ländern die wir in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten benötigen
könnten oder benötigen werden nicht
unnötig belasten aber der Begriff der
staatsreson den ich jetzt fast schon
komm noch den Mund nehmen will so häufig
in den letzten Wochen zitiert worden
bedeutet doch und so ist immer gemeint
worden ein hochrangiges oder
höchstrangiges Staatsziel was über
anderen Staatszielen steht also sagen
was andere Staatsziel wir trumpft und
das ist ja auch auch in der politischen
Debatte in Deutschland damit gemeint
gewesen und das jetzt sozusagen zu
relativieren zu sagen ja staatsrressor
einerseits andererseits kären wir uns
dann doch nicht ganz an die Seite
Israels wenn es opportun ist das fand
ich sehr Unglück und ich glaube das
erklärt auch die Rezeption in Israel wie
fanden sie es ich konnte die Begründung
nachvollziehen ähm und ich verstehe auch
ihre Argumentation
aber die Frage ist ob Deutschland
vielleicht ein besserer oder
effektiverer Freund Israels sein kann
wenn es eben Gesprächskanäle zu Ländern
offen hält und mit anderen Ländern
spricht die die Welt vielleicht nicht
ganz so sehen wie wie wir das tun in
Deutschland und es ist ja offenbar so
dass dass Deutschland dazu beigetragen
hat den Text dieser Resolution zu
verbessern also gearbeitet hat
eingewirkt hat auch mit mit den
Jordanian kommuniziert hat sehr viele
mit anderen dass der Text verbessert
wurde und das allein ist ja schon mal
ein Erfolg und dann hat er eben nicht
den Maßstäben der deutschen entsprochen
am Ende trotzdem immer noch nicht und
dann haben sie sich enthalten aber haben
eben nicht ein schroffes nein
m geäußert den Punkt finde ich sehr sehr
wichtig und ich kann das auch
nachvollziehen wenn man verhandlungs
Erfolge hat und auch wenn man nicht zum
Maximum an Änderungen kommt und das
fehlte ja nicht viel ähm dann mit Nein
zu stimmen ich glaube das hätte die
Jordania die ja auch noch wichtig werden
können äh sehr vor den Kopf gestoßen und
Deutschland hat sehr eng mit den
Kanadiern zusammengearbeitet und
versucht das maximale rauszuholen und
dann ist meiner Ansicht nach die
Enthaltung in der Verhandlungssituation
das Richtige gewesen das Signal äh das
aus israelischer Sicht wahrgenommen wird
auch das kann ich nachvollziehen aber
ich verstehe die Haltung des Auswärtigen
Amtes wir haben in unserer unser
sendetitel Fragen wirin wohin führt
dieser Krieg Herr Segador gibt es
eigentlich Ideen darüber was man macht
wenn diese Bodenoffensive im Sinne
Israels erfolgreich
ist also es gibt erste Kommentare und es
wird hier vor allem in den Medien
natürlich immer wieder die Frage
gestellt welche Lösung gibt es
eigentlich ich weiß nicht ob die
Regierung wirklich sich jetzt schon
profunde Gedanken gemacht hat wie es
dann weitergehen soll es wird jetzt
zumindest überlegt
dass ein Teil der Bevölkerung die jetzt
im Gazastreifen ist möglicherweise in
den Sinai gehen sollte was Ägypten
natürlich kategorisch ablehnt völlig
klar die haben ja auch kein Interesse
aus verschiedenen Gründen wir wissen
dass die Hamas ursprünglich ja aus der
Muslimbruderschaft sich auch entwickelt
hat und elasisi hat überhaupt keine
keine Lust sich hier möglicherweise
Terror zu importieren und auch
Flüchtlinge zu importieren wir wissen
dass es bis heute in Libanon in
Jordanien sehr sehr große
flüchtlingslageer gibt auch in Gaza
selber war ja ein ein riesiges
Flüchtlingslager eigentlich seit dem
Unabhängigkeitskrieg
1948 und diese Schwierigkeiten will sich
eben keiner ans Bein binden um es mal so
salop zu
formulieren nein es gibt eigentlich kein
klares Konzept und es wird jetzt auch
drüber
diskutiert soll das ganze dann von den
arabischen Ländern irgendwie verwaltet
werden dieses neue Konstrukt dieser neue
Gasastreifen soll es eine internationale
Verwaltung sein Israel sagt sie haben
kein Interesse es wieder zu verwalt sind
200 2005 aus dem gaserstreifen raus sie
wollen nicht wieder rein ist es ist
nachvollziehbar fr schffi wie sehen sie
es was was was könnte eine Lösung sein
jetzt kann man sich noch gar nicht
vorstellen dass es überhaupt eine Lösung
gibt aber muss man nicht genau die
mitdenken jetzt ja müsste man und es ist
aber wie sie sagen einfach sehr schwer
vorstellbar was das sein soll also das
Kriegsziel was formuliert wurde ist die
Hamas zerstören Sicherheit herzustellen
ähm was wenn das passiert ist also dann
hat man einen verwüsteten noch stärker
verwüsteten Gazastreifen mit einer
Bevölkerung von über 2 Millionen
Menschen und wer ist dann verantwortlich
für die wer soll dann diese Region
regieren werden die Israelis drin
bleiben die Hoffnung dass Ägypten die
Grenzen öffnet und die Palästinenser
aufnimmt halte ich für sehr sehr sehr
illusorisch aus den Gründen die sie
schon genannt haben dass es einfach die
Sorge vor importierten Terror gibt die
Kapazitätsprobleme man möchte nicht
viele geflüchtete aufnehmen aber auch
aus politischen Gründen ist es einfach
nicht zu
vermitteln aus ägyptischer Sicht dass
man das Problem quasi in
Anführungsstrichen der Bevölkerung von
Gaza den Israelis abnimmt und damit aus
auch wieder aus ägyptischer Sicht die
Palästina Frage für immer faktisch
beendet das wird glaube ich einfach
nicht passieren deswegen ist sehr unklar
was die Zukunft bringt wer ver ja nur
eine ganz kurze Ergänzung
der wir haben es ja vorhin schon gesagt
die Situation in gaserstreifen war ja
vorher schon sehr sehr prekär inzwischen
sind ja fast 50% der Gebäude zerstört
worden jetzt schon und wir sind
eigentlich noch zu Beginn dieses Krieges
das heißt dass im Grunde eine eine
Ruinenlandschaft übrig bleiben wird die
so aussehen wird wie Berlin nach dem
zweiten tkrieg da bin ich fest davon
überzeugt also die dieser Küstenstreifen
wird so nicht mehr lebensfähig sein und
und das ist ein riesen Problem wir
werden über 2 Millionen Flüchtlinge
bekommen und und ich glaube dass es da
wirklich noch keine Vorstellung gibt was
da auf die umliegenden Staaten zukommen
wird und es ist eine sehr junge
Bevölkerung die natürlich wo wo man
natürlich durch diese die das erlebt
haben die natürlich noch mit viel mehr
Hass sozusagen groß werden
letztendlich wer und das wir das das
wird das nur ganz kurz das wird ein
Thema das sicherlich auch Europa
betreffen wird Stichwort Migration also
ich bin mir sicher dass da auf Europa
einiges zukommen wird wer vertritt
eigentlich
die Interessen der Palästinenser der
Zivilbevölkerung zurzeit in der Welt
Frau Schwarzer was würden Sie sagen also
die Vereinten Nationen und
ihre Repräsentanten in der Region
betonen schon sehr stark und immer
wieder gerade auch in den letzten Tagen
wie dramatisch die Situation ist sie
bringen Zahlen raus die uns einen
Eindruck geben wie viel tote es gibt wie
stark die Vertreibung ist wie viel
Flüchtlinge es gibt es gibt auch einige
EU-Staaten wir sprachen ja vorhin
darüber dass die Schwerpunkte in der
Äußerung zu dem Konflikt sehr
unterschiedlich gelegt werden und es
gibt einige Staaten die sowohl den
Angriff der Hamas und die Terrorakte
verurteilen aber gleichzeitig sehr stark
auch auf die palästinensische
Bevölkerung und ihre Notlage Hinweisen
also es gibt diese Vielstimmigkeit auch
in der innereuropäischen Diskussion und
ich denke dass gerade die die letzten
Versuche das wieder Hilfstransporte ins
Land kommen die gingen von den
Amerikanern aus aber auch einige
Europäer haben das sehr stark
unterstützt dass die Grenze geöffnet
wird von Ägypten ausgehend das sind das
sind natürlich versuche diesem Leid
etwas
entgegenzusetzen und ich denke dass wir
dass wir innerhalb der Europäischen
Union weiterhin damit zu tun haben
werden dass es diese
diesen diese Unterschied en Auffassungen
die nicht dazu führen dass irgendjemand
Hamas gut heißt und die Terrorakte aber
trotzdem einen unterschiedlichen
Schwerpunkt legt auf die auf die
Bedeutung der jeweiligen Interessen
Israels und eben der palästinensischen
Zivilbevölkerung dass wir da in in
Europa unterschiedliche Auffassung haben
werden und das mag jetzt erstmal wie
eine Zerstrittenheit wirken aber ich
glaube es kann auch produktiv werden das
könnte auch eine Chance sein dass man
dass man sagt man versucht beide Seiten
beiden Seiten irgendwo gerecht zu werden
und vielleicht dieser Moment und es ist
jetzt noch viel zu früh da ein Szenarien
also man kann drüber nachdenken aber es
ist zu früh zu handeln nur die
Vorbereitung die läuft im Hintergrund
wobei man sagen muss dass die
Palästinenser nie eine Lobby hatten sie
haben keine Lobby sie haben auch im
Übrigen in der arabischen Welt kaum eine
Lobby wenn man ganz ehrlich ist
möglicherweise der der König von
Saudi-Arabien der war sehr sehr
palesstinenser freundlich aber
inzwischen ist ja sein Sohn derjenige
der den Ton angibt und man hat schon
gemerkt bei den Verhandlungen über die
Annäherung mit Israel dass die
Palästinenser da kaum noch eine Rolle
gespielt haben die Abraham Abkommen da
wurde die Palästinenser Frage
ausgeklammert israel hat diplomatische
Beziehungen zu mehreren arabischen
Ländern geknüpft unter ja Auslassung der
Palästinenser Frage und wenn wir uns die
Realitäten Ansehen in Jordanien in im
Libanon in diesen riesigen
Flüchtlingslagern wo Palästinenser sind
die haben nicht mal die
Staatsangehörigkeit dieser Staaten
bekommen die sind staatenlos bis heute
also man sieht die die Palästinenser
haben einfach keine Lobby und das ist
ein riesiges Problem für diese für für
dieses
Volk ja es wird aber auch dadurch zum
Problem dass die internationale
Gemeinschaft ja zugelassen hat dass die
Palästinenser sich selber nicht mehr
artikulieren konnten in den letzten 15
Jahren wann haben s den letzten Mal in
Gaza stattgefunden ich glaube 2006 wann
haben wann haben die letzten malahen in
Westjordanland stattgefunden wir wissen
ja so wenig um nicht zu sagen gar nichts
über die politische Befindlichkeit über
die politischen Präferenz der
Palästinenser und ich glaube dass was
wir über die Hamas gesagt haben kann man
kumgan s das auch über die Regierung
West sagen es ist keine terrorregierung
nicht dass sie missverstanden werde aber
sie ist auch nicht mehr legitimiert also
das heißt ein wichtiger Baustein einer
möglichen ich sage jetzt nicht
Friedensregelung politischen Regelung
nach dem Krieg sollte wäre meines achens
zu allererst einmal demokratische
Legitimation eine demokratisch
legitimierte neue jüngere
palästinensische Führung
herbeizuführen da gab's hoffnungsvolle
äh Signale ich habe gestern gerade mit
einer palästinensischamerikanischen
Politologin in Princeton gesprochen die
in den Tagen vor dem 7 Oktober eine
Umfrage eine repräsentative Umfrage in
Gaza und im Westjordanland durchgeführt
hat und das Ergebnis war dass 80% der
Bevölkerung von Gaza der Befragten
repräsentativ wie gesagt für eine
friedliche Lösung waren und die Mehrheit
der Bevölkerung eine Zweistaatenlösung
immer noch befürwortet hat die
logischerweise das Existenzrecht Israels
voraus setzt also es ist nicht so dass
das was man von der Hamas hört in
irgendeiner Form repräsentativ wäre für
die Bevölkerung von Gaza und wenn man
jetzt nach einem Hoffnungsschimmer sucht
dann kann man vielleicht sagen wir
sprechen jetzt immerhin international
auch wieder über die zwei staatenlösung
die vergessen oder für hoffnungslos
erklärt worden war dann wäre es ja umso
wichtiger dass die Hamas so bekämpft
würde dass sie eben keine Macht mehr hat
das dann andere vielleicht dann doch zum
zugekommen Aufbau von
zivilgesellschaftlichen Strukturen von
Parteistrukturen dass überhaupt Wahlen
durchgeführt werden können dass in der
Gesellschaft überhaupt das Verständnis
da ist dass hier Optionen sind
politischer Natur das dauert seine Zeit
das heißt man muss aber auch diese
Übergangsphase frühzeitig Bedenken und
das nötige dafür tun dass diese
Strukturen entstehen können man hatte
auch eine Zeit lang mal überlegt ob die
Türkei eventuell vermitteln könnte jetzt
hat aber Erdogan sich so klar auf die
Seite der Hamas gestellt als hat sie als
Freiheitskämpfer bezeichnet
kein was wie muss man das denn
einschätzen was bedeutet das dass die
Türkei sich da so so stark positioniert
auch politikater kann manchmal sagen ich
weiß es nicht also ich glaube es ist in
einer Linie mit dieser
erratischen außensicherheitspolitik von
Präsident Erdogan der versucht
einerseits im westlichen Nager zu
bleiben über die natomitgliedschaft auch
das immer wieder betont sich in
normativer Hinsicht aber vielfach schon
vom Westen abgewendet hat also die
innere verfassungsentwickung der Türkei
will ich jetzt hier nicht ausführen aber
zuusagen da kann man fragen ist die
Türkei eigentlich Teil des bestens oder
des Orients aber Türkei ist natoitglied
also was bedeutet was wür ja aber was
würde das bedeuten also wenn die Türkei
sogar damit droht eV türkische Soldaten
in den Gazastreifen zu entsenden also ja
ich glaube die Betonung ist im Moment
auf Drohung und ich würde mir die
Äußerung von Erdogan vor dem Hintergrund
der innenpolitischen Situation
anschauen es ist populär das zu sagen
denn die Solidarität geht mit den
Palästinensern geht über die arabische
Welt hinaus in die weitere muslimische
Welt im Moment er ist gerade
innpolitisch sehr gestärkt also er kann
das machen er feiert 100 Jahre Türkei
also ich sehe das eher in dem
Zusammenhang und natürlich macht er sich
dafür wie er das öfter mal gemacht hat
durch eine Äußerung in der NATO zu
jemanden mit dem man zumindest reden
muss und mit dem man interagieren muss
und mit dem man ja dann auch über diesen
offensichtlichen Konflikt zwischen der
Haltung der natopartner reden muss und
was Erdogan seit Jahren eigentlich macht
ist die Türkei immer mehr zu einem
regionalen Akteur zu einer Mittelmacht
im Nahen und Mittleren Osten zu
entwickeln und ich sehe hier einen
Konflikt mehr wo die Türkei aus einer
früheren Haltung rausgeht und
Aufmerksamkeit auf sich zieht und was
das für die zukünftige Haltung heißt wie
sich die Türkei dann in einer
eventuellen Verhandlungssituation
positioniert das kann man jetzt meiner
Ansicht nach noch nicht sagen aber dass
er eine Rolle spielen will wie auch in
anderen Konflikten das ist für mich
relativ klar wir wiren doch im Falle der
USA wie ich f nochölich zutreffen
rausgearbeitet dass die USA gerade so
großen Einfluss auf die Israelis haben
weil sie so uneingeschränkt auf der
Seite der Israelis stehen also jeder der
sie eine Position betritt bezieht wie
Präsident Erdogan muss akzeptieren dass
die Israelis ihm vom Hof jagen werden
wenn es an eine Nachkriegsordnung gehen
wird und deshalb Leuchte mir das
Vorgehen nicht ein Herr Segador sie
wollten dazu auch was sagen hier in
Israel sind die die Äußerungen von
Erdogan auf großes großes Befremden auch
gestoßen es gab ja auch eine eine sehr
sehr interessante Annäherung zwischen
der Türkei und
und Israel und es war ja eigentlich
geplant dass im Rahmen dieser 100 Jahr
feiern Erdogan
zur alaaka Moschee kommt auf zum alaka
Komplex auf den Tempelberg wie die Juden
sagen und das wäre natürlich ein ein
riesiger Termin geworden auch mit mit
Billigung Israels und da ist man
natürlich jetzt wieder Meilen weit
entfernt davon israel hat das komplette
diplomatische Personal aus Ankara und
Istanbul abgezogen und hier wird einfach
vermutet dass sich Erdogan im Zuge
dieses Konfliktes einfach zu einer
Führungskraft der arabischmuslimischen
Welt aufschwingen möchte was sehr sehr
plausibel klingt mhm aber es wäre die
Frage ob er dann die Interessen der
Palästinenser wirklich
vertritt das das ist eher zu bezweifeln
weil ich glaube nicht dass es so ins
Detail gehen wird und sich um diese
Problematik kümmern wird ich glaube es
geht hier eher um um eine geopolitische
Strategie für die Region für den
nenosten ist es richtig ihn zu empfangen
er soll ja mit ich glaub 17 18 November
nach Berlin kommen FR ist es richtig
oder S würde man dann sagen jetzt nach
dieser Positionierung dann muss
Deutschland sich da stärker
distanzieren sie stellen Fragen ich bin
ja mein
Job meine
auch ich bin ja immer im Zweifel für
Dialog aber ob das mit dem
diplomatischen Protokoll dann jetzt an
der Stelle so sinnvoll ist
müssen andere
entscheiden wenn die Bundesregierung den
EMI von Qatar vor wenigen Wochen
empfangen hat entfällt ein bisschen die
normative Grundlage um den turkischen
Präsidenten in wenigen Wochen nicht zu
empfangen also das finde ich muss man
wirklich in Perspektive Rücken und man
versucht ja alle Gesprächskanäle offen
zu halten mit allen
viele machen sich ja die meisten Sorgen
halt eben ob Iran in irgendein er Form
eingreift die Frage nach der
Hisbollah Beteiligung Herr Keim wie wie
würden sie da im Moment die Lage
einschätzen ist
es die Zurückhaltung die da jetzt ist
kann man der trauen ich finde die
Betonung ist das Stück in Ihrer Frage im
Moment im Moment ist die Lage
vergleichsweise ruhig es gibt Gefechte
an der Nord der Nordgrenze Israels die
finde ich den Charakter von politischen
Botschaft noch nicht überschritten haben
also keine beide Seiten scheinen die
vollausgewiüte feldschlach zu meiden und
das würde ich auch in Zusammenhang
bringen mit dem warahen Signal der
Amerikaner mit den zwei Flugzeugträgern
in die Region zu verlegen das war glaube
ich ganz andeutig an den Iran gerichtet
der mit dieser schattenmizen oder sind
schattenakteuren sein Stellvertreter
Milizen die Saudis P sag die Israelis P
sagt diesen diesen Weg nicht
weiterzugehen aber ob das in nächsten
Wochen und Monaten aufrecht zu halten
ist hängt glaube ich von der Entwicklung
in Gasa ab und von den von der Reaktion
in teiran also anders
formuliert ich würde keine Wette darauf
abgeben dass wir in sech Wochen eine
ruhige Nordfront Israels
haben wie sehen sie die Rolle des Iran
ich würde die Lage genauso analysieren
und die Frage ist
eben wie viel Niederlage der Hamas wird
Iran in Kauf nehmen also wie erfolgreich
darf Israel sein bis Iran dass der Iran
entscheidet stärker einzugreifen und
stärker zu unterstützen glaube das ist
der Punkt wo ich im Moment meine größte
Sorge habe aber letztendlich können wir
in die Köpfe in teiran nicht gucken weil
es nicht im Interesse teirans ist dass
die Hamas so besiegt wird wie Israel das
gerne hätte aber das klingt ja
eigentlich so dass es da gar keinem dass
es ja eigentlich nur ein schlechtes Ende
geben kann ich glaube wir müssen davon
ausgehen dass es ein tatsächliches
Szenario gibt wo sich dieser Konflikt
regional ausweitet ähm und ih der Iran
eine stärkere Rolle spielt
es sei denn man schafft es in
irgendeiner Art und Weise über
Verhandlungslösungen und die Möglichkeit
palästinensischen Interessen besser zu
vertreten und so weiter den Iran davon
zu überzeugen dass sich das nicht lohnt
die USA sind mit zwei Flugzeugträgern da
wegen dieser starken Signalwirkung dass
sie sagen es hätte einen Preis ja
deshalb ist es wahrscheinlich so dass es
erst einmal weiterhin verdeckte
Unterstützung aber vielleicht stärkere
gibt die Frage ist bleibt es beim Signal
oder gibt es dann halt eben wirklich ein
ein Eingreifen ja Herr Segador wie viel
Angst hat man in Israel im Moment vor
der Reaktion des Iran und auch der
hisbolla und einem einem
Zweifrontenkrieg na ja dass der Iran im
Hintergrund die Fäden zeht daran gibt es
hier eigentlich überhaupt keinen Zweifel
der Iran hat seine Proxis ob es die
hisbolla ist ob es die Hamas ist
sichlich begrenzten Maße das Verhältnis
zwischen Iran und und der Hamas ist
glaube ich sehr sehr interessant aber
das würde jetzt zu weit führen wir haben
jetzt die die die Hufi Rebellen die
heute
Langstreckenwaffen nach Israel gefeuert
haben die von zum ersten Mal jetzt auch
von Arrow
Abfangraketen gestoppt werden konnten
das ist schon eine andere Dimension und
vorhin hat Herr Keim ja auch gesagt da
gebe ich ihm absolut Recht dass es im
Grunde ich sag's ein bisschen salop was
sich da an der Nordgrenze zum Libanon
abspielt echt noch ein geplenkel ist wir
wissen die hisbolla hatten ganz anderes
waffenasenal als die Hamas äh die haben
150.000
äh Raketen Langstreckenwaffen
mittelstreckenwaffen die können zu jedem
Zeitpunkt jeden Fleck Israels erreichen
und das und die können Israel sehr sehr
weh tun da würden auch die
abfangsysteme nicht hundertprozentig
funktionieren dann wärden wir in einem
ganz anderen Konflikt aber soweit sind
wir noch nicht und ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob der Iran die hisbolla wirklich
opfern will weil er sie möglicher Weise
für andere Dinge noch braucht wenn im
Zuge des Atomprogramms möglicherweise
Israel mit den Vereinigten Staaten
wirklich den Iran angreifen würde dann
ich glaube dann und das habe ich in
einigen Hintergrundgespräch mit hohen
Militärs so ein bisschen raushören
können dann wäre der Zeitpunkt da wo der
Iran die hisbolla opfert ich bezweifel
dass das jetzt der Fall ist aber wir
wissen nicht wie die Dynamik eines
solchen Konfliktes ist wenn es jetzt
sehr sehr blutig wird wenn die arabische
Welt wirklich sagt hier sind die die
allerletzten roten Linien überschritten
worden dann kann das natürlich passieren
dann genügt ein Funke insofern sind wir
natürlich hier im Bereich der
Spekulation aber ich würde einfach von
der Einschätzung her würde ich sagen
dass dass der Konflikt
sicherlich ausgeweitet wird noch vor
allem in der Westbank das wir haben ja
hier mehrere Fronten wir haben im Grunde
und wenn sie die arabischen Israelis
nehmen noch eine Front innerhalb des
Landes hatten wir alle schon das dass es
hier aufständig gab also da blicken die
Israelis mit viel viel Sorge auf diese
einzelnen Fronten sie sind aber auch gut
gerüstet also der Norden ist sehr sehr
gut gesichert ebenso die die Westbank
die ja hermetisch abgeriegelt ist nun
seit Tagen oder seit Wochen schon aber
ich glaube der Iran überlegt sich sehr
sehr gut ab wann er die hisbolla
wirklich opfert okay Frau schaffi was
denken Sie was ist ihre Idee wie lange
mit dieser Krieg dauern und ist es ein
eine Möglichkeit die dieser Konflikt
jetzt irgendwie in in ja irgendwie
friedlicher wird oder zu einem
Waffenstillstand kommt solange Netanyahu
da auch an der Macht ist ja es wird
immer wieder gesagt dass Netanyahu ja in
diesem Krieg auch um sein politisches
Überleben kämpft
dass sich da persönliche Interessen mit
den Interessen des Landes vermischen
es gibt allerdings weil Israel ein
demokratisches Land ist ja auch
Opposition und kritische Stimmen und
Stimmen die sagen eigentlich geht das
mit diesem Premierminister so nicht
weiter
ähm es wird sich zeigen ob er ob er es
schafft Rückhalt noch mal zu finden ähm
für für seine Politik oder oder ob es
ähm ob es irgendwann auch Kräfte gibt
die
ähm die es vielleicht schwierig machen
für ihnen im Amt zu bleiben mhm her ke
was denken Sie auf wie auf welche Dauer
müssen wir uns einstellen jetzt dass
diese Bodenoffensive begonnen wird es
Monate dauern kann das schneller gehen
wie muss man sich das vorstellen also
über die militärische Dynamik können wir
jetzt nicht sagen das wir hochkadeis
spekulativ ich glaube man kann den
politischen Kontext noch mal in
Erinnerung rufen ich würde von einem
doppelten legitimitätsfenster sprechen
was die Israelis haben im Moment gilt
alles das was sie tun noch weitgehend
als legitim durch die eignisse vom 7
Oktober wir haben drüber gesprochen das
erodiert so langsam die Kritik steigt
also in der internationalen Gemeinschaft
mehren sich die kritischen Stimmen und
in dem Sinich das Doppelte das doppeltes
digitimitätsfenster nennen mit Bezug auf
die israelische Innenpolitik im Moment
scharen sich alle schließlich in dem
Premierminister zusammen aus
nachvollziehbaren Gründen auch da würde
ich nicht wetten dass das in sech
Monaten noch der Fall ist und ich glaube
das sind die beiden variaben auf die wir
gucken müssen wenn wir über die
Entschlossenheit der israelischen
Führung sprechen diesen Krieg
weiterzuführen aber es liegt
letztendlich an den USA um es zu lösen
es liegt an den Israelis und also wie
sie ihrer Strategie weiterentwickeln
aber was wichtig ist ist dass natürlich
die USA nicht nur diesen Konflikt im
Blick haben genauso wenig wie die
Europäer und wir haben jetzt gesehen wie
sehr explizit die Verbindung zu dem
Krieg Russlands in der Ukraine gezogen
wde auf Seiten der USA weil ein
gemeinsames Unterstützungspaket erstmals
in den Senat eingebracht wurde das zeigt
eben auch es gibt tradeoffs und deshalb
ist die Frage wie lange der Westen
welchen Krieg noch unterstützt die ist
noch nicht beantwortet und die versuchen
wir morgen zu beantworten in der
phönixrunde dann heißt unser Titel
nämlich der Westen und die die Kriege
was wird aus der Unterstützung für die
Ukraine weil man die ja doch durch
diesen Krieg dort im Nahen Osten etwas
aus dem Blick im Moment verloren hat
deshalb freue ich mich wenn sie da
morgen dabei sind bedank mich aber
erstmal bei Frau schaff Herrn Keim Frau
Schwarzer und Herrn Segador und alles
Gute und bleiben Sie sicher dort in Tel
Aviv vielen dank vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen bei uns geht's weiter mit
Phönix der Tag und meiner Kollegin Julia
Grimm bis dann
tschüss
[Musik]